people disappear all the time
elaboration like the moment I'd realized
I'd never owned a vast and general lamp
down with accents but how dare you call
a vase of boss I will not stand for it
and anyone who pronounces it that way
will never be welcome in my life just
call me the urologist because I'm over
here snipping all your vast differences
it was a Tuesday afternoon six months
after the end of the war
narration into a flashback this
flashback then goes into reading I'm
pulling the plug of this whole thing Oh
so we've swapped from a slowly paced
narrative about missing people and vases
to a horrific war drama neat she wanders
into the street in a daze after cleaning
up a horrific leg wound and is now
covered in blood spatter but it wasn't
on her when she walked away from the
spurting leg so did she pick it up on
her scroll I'm guessing the show has
blood fountains and honestly I want to
explore why because I have a bad feeling
we're going to get back to the boring
non viscera stuff very soon this entire
episode is going to be ten whistles and
ponderous slow-motion isn't it if the
show were played at a regular speed it
would be over in ten minutes
somehow in my mind as I stood pondering
the first five minutes of the show that
had been set in my purview my mind
drifted to how I should handle an
endeavor that never stops narrating with
excessive and erudite haughtiness sins I
mused thoughts and lots of sins
sometimes wonder what would have
happened if I bought that farce and made
a home for it like a dollhouse situation
where the vase has its own miniature
sized house to live in
that's dump also this lady is so horned
up for this vase that I have to assume
it comes with a pack of batteries 90
seconds of opening theme music
accompanied by spoil eerie images that
look like someone thought Nicholas
Sparks movies were too subtle also
seriously these credits look like a
montage of every war movie ever made
and by based on what we really mean is
that we turned this into a glorified
audiobook version of the material
because we'll do any work ourselves when
we could just have the main character
think to themselves the words someone
else already wrote seem to be surrounded
by homes mauve blood thank you captain
Randall or obvious parking on the
sidewalk
I'm afraid my husband's this toyline
slow down Joe Jesus you can't just add
history buffs into this riveting tale
without giving me time to freshen up on
my Scottish folklore event there's one
thing I love it's a show that feels like
I'm reading Wikipedia I have to face of
a mr. vaudeville
every hotel needs a curious and chatty
manager on duty how else would we get
all the convenient check-ins position
Sian became
Halloween you'll became Christmas and
that poor woman just pulled a muscle in
her face from holding her fake smile mr.
Randall takes forever to sign the
[ __ ] book
mind you ghosts are freed on the
Beasties they'll be wondering about this
show now seems to be a combination of
romance novel and campfire ghost story
and I cannot say skip fast enough you
didn't even take your shoes off when you
jumped on the bit and now you're gonna
have sex in the bed you want herpes
because I'm pretty sure that's how you
get herpes
Frank's passion for history damn it more
narration look I know I've sent it a
bunch in this already but this is
next-level laziness it gets worse
exponentially every time there's only
one thing to do that's right narration
exponents characters shift immediately
before saying something probably
important and is then probably give it a
[ __ ] cliche stalking organism uncle
lamb is an archaeologist and now the
show is jonesing for some archaeology
tropes
we're not even 15 minutes in I'm
drowning in this genre gumbo Frank's
newfound passion was genealogy are you
kidding me right now we have nature
history genealogy and more could we mine
was botany great botany just what we
need to spice this up we're all saved
let's see what happens next I'm so
[ __ ] excited by the possibility of a
plant-based plot development oh and also
I developed a keen interest in the use
of plants and herbs for medicinal
purposes if by medicinal purposes you
mean getting through the rest of this
show then right there with you on the
herbs seven Kappa did you see that Gleek
I could never figure out how to do that
I tried and tried while my buddy JC
could Gleek on command take me on this
is for you Gleevec liquors out there
province of the castle Hermit perhaps of
troll or to Twitter and then dizzy you
can give me a bath I swear the subtitle
of this show should have been 101 ways
to get a yeast infection I distinctly
heard the barman in the pub last night
refer to us as SAS let's roll
commercials it only means Englishmen
after all or at worst a blender double
roll commercials also is anyone else in
the scene concern with the amount of
smoke coming out of the fireplace and
into the room
check your flue Marisha so long since
I've had a good cup of fulong you know
what the show needs to really spice it
up a conversation about tea oh I had a
terrible time with that all green oh do
go on the leaves fall apart so fast it's
hard to tell anything at all okay I
can't pretend anymore so goddamn bored
is the curved leaf
which indicates adjoining readings to be
polite about it
your husband is near like lead astray
far from your bed considering you're
reading her sexual drive as only meant
to serve a man's pleasure I think you
may have meant to say to be racist about
it most divided lanes are broken yours
is forked considering how obvious this
expositional palm reading is I'm
thinking the whole show might be forked
I'd never put any stock and superstition
and looks like you've seen a ghost
character says you look like you've seen
a ghost after someone has likely indeed
seen a ghost cliche I swear if Fabio
isn't on the cover of the blu-ray case
for this series they've totally missed
the boat
sex was our bridge back to one another
so according to local folklore these
turns were carried here from Africa by a
race of Celtic Giants Bill Russell
Robert Parish and Kevin Garnett show up
carrying stones right now I'm giving
every single sin back and then doubling
them back on because Boston this Druids
on for some time they should have been
ridiculous and perhaps they were they
were oh and also no one will be seated
during the druid ritual dance to open up
a portal to historical hell portion of
the program no seriously the middle of
this episode is just as dark confusing
and witchy as well the ending of the
[ __ ] once traveling at night perhaps I
had stumbled onto the set of a cinema
company filming a costume drama of some
sort then why are you running away
before you even realize the guns are
real you think you're accidentally on a
set why aren't you trying to get
someone's attention
I'm Jonathan Randall Esquire captain of
his Majesty's Headz dragoons oh I see
it's Frank's ancestor I wish they could
have made it more obvious so I didn't
have to look up the episode guide I mean
couldn't you have half the same actor
wear new clothes with longer hair also
great we've added time travel to this
conglomeration which is fine because
that's always handled perfectly without
confusion or paradox
yes rescue the damsel but miss a clear
opportunity to easily kill your enemy I
wanted it to be a dream you mustn't move
the joint for two or three days and you
begin to use it again very slowly at
first and now we've added medical jargon
settle in folks this show has a hundred
ways to bore you and it's gonna use
every single one
see up that dang it sure I was there
thirty minutes to go when this
conversation happened the first time I
was paying attention and I don't need
you cutting back to remind me but force
feeding us and trust your audience which
way to go now woods or what I suppose
that means you're coming with me
well not yet but knowing the show I'm
sure she'll be coming with you soon
I can handle a single great coffee one
hand maybe even to not see you have
three hands well someone's never
listened to the behind-the-scenes
podcast have they considering she just
tore part of her dress to bandage his
wound
why is it so intact now and you might
say but maybe she tore it from somewhere
else and I would say well I've been here
with Frank
two days ago jesus H Roosevelt Christ
you science make sure you click that
Bell icon but clicking the little bell
icon is how you make sure you get
notified every time we release a video
so click it top there that's like [ __ ]
Naaman wrong uncle an was an
archaeologist Aziz
who was this love of yours another
Prince like this one ugly rich scabby no
see how it it commands the high ground
in every direction it's over Anakin as a
beeping I'm a nurse not a wet nurse mama
know you'll be telling me exactly her
and why you come to know there's an
anger shop ahead I don't know but I
heard the Redcoats he's Cottenham the
almighty says don't change the subject
just answer the question